- Unlike the first two movies,
the third Conjuring doesn't begin
with a cold open showing us another case
from the history of Ed
and Lorraine Warren,
but that doesn't mean the
opening doesn't reference
another well known exorcism.
The entire style of the open,
in particular the shots
of Father Gordon arriving at the house,
pay tribute to the iconic
shots of Father Merrin
from The Exorcist, an image also featured
on The Exorcist movie poster.
The way that David Glatzel,
the young boy who is possessed,
moves and convulses is very reminiscent
of what happens to
Regan in The Exorcist.
Obviously The Exorcist
kind of set the stage
for an entire genre of exorcism movies,
which includes the original Conjuring,
which I've already analyzed
on Things You Missed.
But the reason this third
installment references
the 1973 horror film
so heavily may be because
The Exorcist movie itself
could have influenced the real version
of the allegedly possessed
killer, Arne Johnson.
In 1981, the cultural impact
of the film was still fresh
and Satanic panic was
on the rise in the 80s.
According to the New York Times,
Debbie Glatzel had
watched The Exorcist on TV
with her family and attended at least one
of the Warrens' lectures
before her brother began
to claim his visions of the devil.
So William Friedkin's famous movie
may have actually influenced
the entire chain of events.
To learn about all of the secret details
that reference both the
greater Conjuring universe
and real events upon which the
fictional story was inspired,
stick around to the end of this video.
(dramatic music)
Like that new intro?
Welcome to Things You Missed.
The name of this movie
is The Conjuring: The Devil Made Me Do It.
However, I don't wanna say
that long title every time,
so I'll be calling it The Conjuring 3,
and before you send your death threats
over me calling it that,
keep in mind that James
Wan even called it that.
So, if you're gonna kill me,
gonna have to take him out too.
However, James Wan was not
the director of this movie.
It would instead be Michael Chaves,
who directed The Curse of La Llorona.
Let's get into the Things You Missed.
(upbeat music)
Once again, the main character drama
for the Warrens involves them getting
into danger by being involved in the case.
This time, Ed starts to
experience heart problems.
In the movie, we see that this
heart condition is a result
of an attack by the demon itself.
DEMON: I'll stop your heart old man!
- The real Ed Warren
did have a heart attack,
supposedly he had several
in his later years,
but it wasn't during this
case and it obviously
wasn't related to demonic
activity, but rather,
probably related to a
lifestyle of unhealthy choices.
- LORRAINE: Somebody call 911!
- You're not supposed to do that Lorraine,
you're supposed to point
at someone and say,
"You, call 911."
Otherwise everyone assumes
someone else will do it.
After the hysteria calms down a bit,
we're introduced to the house
where the crime would take place
in a long, continuous shot.
This is how we were introduced
to the Old Arnold Estate
in The Conjuring 1,
and the house in The Curse of La Llorona
although, in The Conjuring 3,
it's more symbolic of just carrying
on the tradition than anything else.
In The Conjuring, it was the perfect way
to teach the audience
the layout of the house
where we'd be spending most of the movie.
And three, we don't really
go back to that house,
so it's more for show.
There's another familiar
piece of camera work later
in the movie where we
see the Satanic ritual
being performed, and the
camera flips upside-down
to signify the presence of evil,
just like it does as Lorraine enters
and exits the basement
where Bathsheba is located
in The Conjuring 1.
Arne helps his girlfriend's
boss fix his stereo,
and in the background there's a poster
for Mack the Knife, which
would be a foreshadowing
of what could happen next.
As Saul dances to this Blondie song,
Arne has a vision where, for a moment,
it looks like Debbie
is dancing up against her boss.
This is kind of a quick
reference to an aspect
of the real life event.
According to the Pensacola News Journal,
the police believed that
Debbie and her boss,
whose real name is Alan Bono,
may have had a romantic relationship,
and that the argument may not
have been about the stereo,
but that they were actually
quarreling over Debbie,
and things escalated because
alcohol was involved.
Though I can't say I
understand how the police
would have come to that conclusion.
We see Arne's point of view,
where he sees this evil
entity rushing him.
At first, it has the sharp
white specs for eyes,
much like we see on Janice
in Annabelle Creation,
but as it gets closer it
has the unnatural yellow glow similar
to Valak's eyes in The Conjuring 2.
I think this is done to kind
of honor the history of the franchise.
We don't actually see
the crime take place,
which plays nicely with the idea that even
in The Conjurverse,
where the paranormal clearly exists,
there are always going to
be believers and skeptics.
The victim also still
has living relatives,
so changing the character's name
and not showing the knife go in
is probably at least a little
bit of a respectful move.
After Arne's arrest,
the Warrens perform these tests
to see if he's housing an inhuman spirit.
I'm not sure why they're so
confident that this will work.
You'd think they might remember
the tests they performed
in The Conjuring 2, three
and a half years ago.
Speaking of things that
haven't always been consistent,
let's talk about the Warrens' house.
In the first film we only really see the
areas connected to the stair hallway
with the flower wallpaper.
Conjuring 2 shows the office,
a kitchen, a living room and this study.
And Annabelle Comes Home
has the same office,
but a different kitchen and living room,
and it's here that we learn the layout
of the rest of the house.
Conjuring 3 seems to use the same layout.
This is the dining room where
Judy held her birthday party.
Those are the stairs
up towards Judy's room.
Ed wakes up in the room where
Judy encountered the ghost
of the wedding dress.
So considering that the
timeline looks like this,
it's now clear that the house used
in Annabelle Comes Home was a retcon,
as opposed to the idea that
they remodeled after that,
but at least we have a
consistent layout going forward.
Goodbye, mysterious room that
isn't connected to anything.
The Warrens listen back
to their audio interviews
of the family,
and we see a flashback
to the day they moved
into the house and they're unloading boxes
from a Saunders Moving Company truck.
This is a sneaky reference
to the travel co-ordinator of the movie,
Ashley Renee Saunders.
I cover crew reference
easter eggs like this
in nearly every episode
of Things You Missed,
but putting the travel
co-ordinator on a moving truck
has gotta be one of the most
creative ones I've seen.
I've also covered a lot
of James Wan movies,
and talked about how moving
is a common theme for him,
it happens in The Conjuring,
Dead Silence and twice in Insidious.
As I mentioned,
The Conjuring 3 wasn't
directed by James Wan,
but I think it's still worth noting
because Michael Chaves is trying
to emulate his style with this.
But Chaves is also his own person,
with his own personal influences.
As Lorraine investigates the house,
she pulls out a camera to get
some photographic evidence,
and this is the camera
used by Carl Kolchak
in the 1974 The Night Stalker.
I'm guessing Chaves is probably a fan.
But the biggest connection
in The Conjuring 3 gives us more insight
to one big mystery left open
in the Annabelle spin-offs.
(tense music)
(upbeat soft music)
(suspenseful music)
(screaming)
Desperate for leads about
their discovery of the witch's
totem under the house,
Father Gordon has a suggestion about where
to look next.
- Do you remember the priest
who helped expose The Disciples
of the Ram cult?
It would have been about 10-12 years ago?
- If you've seen my episodes
covering the Annabelle movies,
all about The Disciples of Ram.
It's explained on a TV playing
in the background in Annabelle 1 that they
are a Charles Manson led cult looking
to make ritual sacrifices in hopes
of summoning a demon.
We know that two of these
cult members pass away
after successfully completing the ritual,
and we know that the
demon ends up eventually
being sealed away in the
Warren's cursed artifact room,
but we never learned what
happened to the other members
of the cult until now: Father
Kastner tried to help them,
but was unable to,
because their sole aim
was to spread chaos.
There's also a more salient reference
to The Conjuring 1.
Roll it.
- LORRAINE: You should burn all this.
- KASTNER: I'd thought of it.
But I felt it was safer
to keep them locked.
Like taking guns off the streets.
- I don't understand why Lorraine
doesn't know that already,
because these are literally
the same words that Ed used
to explain the danger of cursed objects
to a reporter.
- It's safer for these things
to be in here than out there.
It's kind of like keeping
guns off the street.
- Well why not just throw
them in an incinerator?
Destroy them?
- Well that would only destroy the vessel.
- Maybe witch objects don't work the same
as cursed vessels?
You'd think Lorraine
would be on top of this.
You'd also think Ed would be smart enough
to follow his own advice and
not touch one of the objects.
- ED: Don't touch it.
- Ed ends up being controlled
by this demon himself later
in the movie,
but Lorraine does not,
so I wonder if touching that book
is what ended up making him vulnerable.
- Ed, don't.
- Then there's this idol
seen on a bookshelf.
It may look kind of like Malthus,
but it's wings make it
more similar to Baphomet,
a deity worshipped by the Knights Templar
that was active starting
in the 12th century.
Baphomet may be another mythological demon
that the creators could explore
in a future Conjuring universe film.
There are a lot of other
options introduced as well,
as the gang is trying to figure out who
or what this demon that
possessed Arne actually is
and list all of their options
on this big chalkboard.
We can only really see the
left side of the board,
which lists the clues they found
from Father Kastner's collection.
Some of these seem to
be just made up words,
while others are more specific references.
We'd be here for a while if
I went through all of them,
but you can pause as we go if you want,
and I'll just list the ones I could see
maybe being the subject
of a future Conjuring spin-off movie.
But just to be clear,
I don't think these items are listed here
as a specific clue for some future movie,
this is obviously just set decoration
that we're not really
supposed to pause and read,
but it's just nice to know
what's on their radar I guess,
so let's go through them.
The Fallen.
Apostasy of the Weak.
Daemonium Rex.
Walpurgisnacht.
Rituals of Roanoke Witches.
Yellow King.
Abaddon Amas.
Balaam.
Conjuring of Ishtar.
Kali Mamoon.
I will not attempt to pronounce this one,
but it refers to an Aztec
god of night and sorcery.
Again, none of these
are concrete references
to anything previously
appearing in the Conjurverse,
I just thought it would
be fun to explore some
of the avenues that the
Warrens might have researched
in this movie.
If you want more of a concrete reference,
you can find one when Ed
and Lorraine return home
after visiting Father
Kastner's own artifact room.
Roll it.
- LORRAINE: Look what
the Perron Family sent.
- ED: Oh, that was sweet of them.
- The Perron Family,
is of course the family that Ed
and Lorraine helped save in
the original Conjuring film.
So it's nice to see
that they've kept in
touch for a decade now
in the movies.
Because if you've seen
my Conjuring 1 episode,
that they didn't exactly stay
on good terms in real life.
There's also a nice little
detail on the fridge.
In Annabelle Comes Home,
Lorraine expresses a desire
to take a road trip out
West with the family.
- That actually sounds so nice.
Ed, we should plan on that.
- Based on this family
photo, which was not there
in Annabelle Comes Home,
it looks like they probably
did take that trip.
The Warrens end up going on
a side-quest to track down
this missing girl, Jessica Strong,
which leads them to visit the
town of Danvers, Massachusets.
In the car, the song
"Suspicious Minds" comes
on the radio, and Lorraine comments
that she actually met Elvis
both before and after his death
and looks at her husband,
making reference to Ed's
killer Elvis impression
that we saw when he was
helping the Hodgson family
in The Conjuring 2.
- Thank you.
(children laughing)
Hey don't laugh now.
Thank you very much.
- After Superhero Lorraine
uses her psychic abilities
to find out what happened to the girl,
they spend the night in the Bruneau Motel.
This is another crew reference easter egg,
probably left there by
Eric and Ian Bruneau,
the visual effects producer
and a technician respectively.
Using the information they collected,
they determine that
their guy Arne is cursed.
- LORRAINE: That means we
know that this is a curse,
and curses can be broken.
- Hell yeah, they can!
The couple decides to try to make contact
with the person who issued this curse,
and the best way to do this
is by visiting the body.
So, they arrive at the
Palmeri Funeral Home.
Palmeri really is a huge
empire in the Conjurverse.
Annabelle had the Palmeri apartments,
Annabelle Creation had
the Palmeri Toy Shop.
And even Lights Out,
which is not even part of the Conjurse,
but is a fellow Warner Bros horror film,
had Palmeri Elementary.
David F Sandberg, who directed Lights Out
and Annabelle Creation,
happens to be a fellow
content creator and filled us
in on the meaning of
Palmeri in the comments
of my Annabelle Creation episode.
It's a reference to Victoria Palmeri
who works at New Line.
The funeral home is closed
when Ed and Lorraine arrive,
so they do their best Clear
Rivers from Final Destination
and decide to break in.
- Gives me a rush.
- Lorraine is able to come face-to-face
with the occultist, Isla,
or as I call her: The Malnourished Lady,
during one of her astral projections,
but Ed has to pull her out
when she's attacked by this evil force.
(monster groans)
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
Before Ed and Lorraine return home,
their assistant guy Drew finds
a book that might help them
because it's a Conjuring movie,
of course they find a
book that might help them.
Ed discovers that the curse can be broken
by destroying the altar it was cast from,
but isn't able to read much further.
- ED: This part looks like Aramaic.
This next part, I can't read it.
- Aramaic is an ancient language
spoken in the Middle East,
which is yet another
potential tie to The Disciples
of Ram from Annabelle,
whose cult was partly based
on an ancient text found
on the bank of the Dead
Sea in that region.
I did a whole video about
Malthus, the Annabelle demon,
so if you're interested in learning more
about that connection,
definitely check that one out.
Given that Conjuring 3 seems to be
so heavily linked to Annabelle,
it's kind of cool that after
Ed answers a phantom knock
on his door, the spot that Isla appears
is practically the same
spot that Annabelle appeared
in behind Judy's babysitter
when she answered
to a ghostly presence knocking at the door
in Annabelle 3.
After nearly being manipulated
to attack his own wife,
Ed realizes that he
too is being influenced
by a witch's totem hidden
somewhere in the house
and goes on a mad tirade to find it.
While searching in the office,
I noticed these two
paintings in the background.
This one looks like the
Penfield Reef lighthouse,
which is a supposedly haunted
lighthouse in Connecticut
where the Warrens live,
but as far as I know,
they've never actually made
an investigation into it
in real life.
The other painting is
the one he was working on
in Annabelle Comes Home.
I don't think it references
anything specific,
but it's just a cool detail
to show that passage of time.
Late that night,
Lorraine goes to visit
Father Kastner again,
hoping he could help
translate the foreign text,
and there is a very familiar scene
of him locking the door
behind her as she comes in,
leading her to the basement,
and creepily waiting for her in the dark.
- GRAYSMITH: Not many people
have basements in FAIRFIELD.
- Not everyone will get that reference,
but I'd just like to point out
that both movies have a Key Largo poster.
That can't be a coincidence.
(bright upbeat music)
So that just leaves us
with the final battle,
where it seems that
Superhero Lorraine Warren
has finally met her match.
I think it's symbolic how Isla attempts
to stab Lorraine in the eye.
Lorraine's main source of strength
is through her psychic visions,
and considering how she
sees these images as sort
of an overlay of her literal vision,
she might not be able to have her gift
without her eyes.
The whole Ed Warren
going after his loved one
with a sledgehammer part
is very The Shining,
where in the book,
Jack Torrance chases his
son with a large mallet.
But after taking care of Isla,
and freeing Ed from her control,
there's one more issue,
when Ed forgets his heart
pills and Lorraine reveals
that she kept an extra on her,
hidden inside the locket on her necklace.
Observant fans will
notice that this is more
than just a sweet gesture towards, Ed.
This is the same locket given
to Lorraine by Judy ten years
before in The Conjuring 1.
- JUDY: Me and Nana got these
at the church's yard sale.
One for you and one for me.
- As always, Ed transfers
one of the cursed objects
from this case, the chalice,
to the Warren's occult
museum of cursed artifacts,
where we see everything
from their past cases accounted for
even if some stuff has been
moved around a little bit
in the almost four years
since The Conjuring 2.
We see the music box from The Conjuring,
The color wheel from Annabelle Comes Home,
The Crooked Man Zootrope
toy from The Conjuring 2,
The Valak painting from The Conjuring 2
and The Annabelle doll
from obviously Annabelle,
The trial of Arne Johnson
ends up just being more
of an epilogue.
As always, the result is
a lot more fictionalized
for movie audiences.
The reason we don't really
see any of the trial could be
because Arne's lawyer
didn't ultimately end up
using the "Devil Made Him
Do It" defense in court,
because the judge said that
this defense would not be allowed.
So his lawyer changed
his plea to say that it
was an act of self defense.
The text in the movie says
Arne served five years,
which is true.
He was sentenced for 10-20 years,
but got out early on good behavior.
The end credits use the
same slideshow style
from The Conjuring 2.
Like The Conjuring 2,
there are some subliminal images that pop
on-screen for just one or two frames.
One of these is an
actual newspaper article.
I found the most interesting
part to be this paragraph,
Meanwhile, the parents
of the 11-year-old boy
say the spirits remain.
Another one that I found
particularly creepy was this one,
it appears to be Arne being
exorcized at the prison
and trashing about in
an almost inhumane way.
There's also this pretty chilling picture
of the malnourished lady Isla,
or at least the demon that possessed her.
Strangely, we never really learn much
about the demon itself,
a stark contrast to the
rich lore behind entities
like Valak, Bathsheba and Malthus.
Then of course, there's
a shot of Annabelle,
don't be surprised if we
haven't seen the last of her.
This last one appears
to be an illustration
of the real Arne Johnson.
You may be wondering how the
Warrens got Debbie Glatzel
and her family to go along
with the whole demonic possession story.
According to History vs Hollywood,
the brother of the 11
year old David claimed
that the Warrens promised
the family money and fame
to the tune of millions of dollars,
but only ended up making them about $2K.
Of course the Warrens denied
this, there was a lawsuit.
money makes the world go round.
I'd like to bring your
attention to the playlist
on the left which contains
Things You Missed episodes
on every movie in the Conjurverse to date.
And for even more Conjuring analysis,
make sure you're subscribed to CZsWorld.
I'll be uploading new horrors every week,
so ring the deathbell
for ALL notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
(tense music)